la lutte contre les violences conjugales
est une nécessité personne ici n'en
doute la volonté du gouvernement a se
mobiliser en faveur des droits des
femmes et à lutter contre les violences
faites aux femmes ne fait également
aucun doute lors des rencontres sur le
terrain avec les gendarmes et les
policiers nous voyons bien que la prison
compte de la parole des femmes à
radicalement changé ces dernières années
aujourd'hui le personnel est formé les
lieux d'accueil sont repensés pour
favoriser la discrétion permettre les
conditions indispensables à la relation
de confiance pour permettre la
libération de la parole et des
intervenants sociales sont également
présentes dans ces lieux si nous pouvons
saluer les résultats des politiques
impulsés ces dernières années nous
sommes néanmoins tous d'accord sur un
point il y a encore beaucoup à faire
que sait-on concernant ces violences
la violence conjugale touche tout le
monde quel que soit l'âge le sexe la
profession le milieu social la religion
la culture ou l'orientation sexuelle
tous les couples engagés dans une
relation violente dans tous ses couples
là il y a un risque élevé que les
agressions deviennent récurrentes et que
leur fréquences s'accélèrent lorsque le
cycle de la violence est engagé il ne
s'arrête pas
les enfants les enfants sont qu'aux
victimes de la violence conjugale qui
les affecte tant sur le plan physique
émotionnel que social donc l'enjeu du
départ de la victime est primordiale
quelques chiffres rapides en 2020 on a
recensé
159 400 victimes de violences conjugales
125 féminicides ces femmes sont mortes
dans leur propre foyers
l'enjeu du départ de la victime ou
l'éviction de l'agresseur du domicile
quand il est possible est absolument
fondamentale et cette étape est
difficile oui le chemin peut être long
il s'effectue par étape par des
allers-retours plus qu'un chemin c'est
un processus pour lequel nous devons
accompagner informer la victime en
respectant ses choix et aider
il y a nous le savons de nombreux freins
amenant la victime à rester au sein du
foyer des sentiments contradictoires
amour peur crainte de perdre les enfants
crainte des représailles et savoir que
toute sa vie est à reconstruire et bien
sûr des freins financiers en raison de
l'absence de revenus le revenu
insuffisants mais aussi de non accès à
ses propres revenus par la main mise du
conjoint sur les comptes bancaires on
parle ici de violences économiques il
faut dès lors penser une aide permettant
de se libérer du jou- financier du
conjoint c'est ce que propose cette
proposition de loi via la création du
net financière disponible à rapidement
elle doit rendre la séparation possible
au moment où les victimes sont prêtes à
quitter le domicile
en commission le groupe démocrate et
indépendant a souligner l'importance de
soutenir une telle aide en émettant
quelques réserves uniquement motivées
par le souci de l'effectivité de cette
proposition et de sa mise en œuvre sur
l'ensemble du territoire des amendements
du couvercle du gouvernement ont été
déposés en ce sens il concourent aux
mêmes objectifs de sécurisation et
d'autonomie des victimes et de dédatures
pas le projet porté en commission je ne
peux donc que vous inciter chers
collègues aller voter
cependant ne croyons pas que les seuls
aides financières seuls définitivement
les problèmes auxquels les victimes font
face dans le processus dont je parlais
précédemment quitter le domicile est une
étape ce n'est pas la fin du parcours
les sortir de ce cycle deviennent
violence et de dépendance psychologique
et affective implique davantage qu'une
seule réponse financière cela appelle
une réponse coordonnée rapide et
continue des pouvoirs publics l'enjeu
est donc de répondre rapidement à la
pluralité des besoins qu'ils soient je
le répète financier psychologique
juridique et bien sûr d'hébergement qui
restent une véritable préoccupation pour
les personnes qui quittent leur foyer
c'est tout l'enjeu il me semble du pack
nouveau départ annoncé en septembre
dernier par la première ministre et
rappeler aujourd'hui même par vous
madame la ministre qui sera déployée de
manière progressive dès le premier
trimestre 2023 il permettra notamment
une meilleure détection des victimes de
violences conjugales grâce à réseau
d'acteurs sur tout le territoire un
renforcement de l'allé vert la victime
aux étapes clés de son parcours une
priorisation de l'accès aux aides et
dispositifs aux bénéfices des victimes
de violence
vous l'aurez compris
votre a favorablement ce texte je vous
remercie
merci